لقد كان قائدًا متوازنًا مثيرًا للإعجاب
، تم إحضاره في
سلاح الجو ، وهي مهنة
تحتاج إلى الاهتمام بالتفاصيل والتركيز
والسيطرة ، لقد كان ملتزمًا بشدة
بها كما تعلم في عهد مبارك على
مدى عدة عقود وانتقد إسرائيل من
وقت لآخر عدة  في المرات التي أعاد فيها
سفيره ، لكنه لم يتأثر أبدًا
فيما يتعلق بعملية السلام ، حتى عندما
توغلت الدبابات الإسرائيلية في
عاصمة عربية مجاورة في بيروت ، شعر
بالالتزام من خلال فهم
متوقع للقدرات العسكرية الإسرائيلية
حول تركيزه كان
حقًا في  داخليًا على إطعام الستينيات
والسبعينيات ثم 80 مليون مصري في
ظل ظروف مستحيلة من
اقتصاد متخلف للغاية تم اختياره بشكل كبير
ومعقد ، فقد ركز
كثيرًا على الحفاظ على الاستقرار داخل
الأفراد أيضًا تحدًا عميقًا
وبالطبع على الحفاظ على الدور القيادي
مصر في الوطن العربي